[Music]
you know there's always been racism in
the world um and there always will be
contrary to the convenient ad hoc
arbitrary definition the left gives the
word today racism is simply the hatred
toward or resentment of another group of
people based on their skin color racism
is it's not a single word somebody says
it's not a joke they make racism also is
not dependent on power structures or
systems or institutions
any old schlub can be a racist
and the racism of the least powerful is
no more justified than the racism of the
most powerful
racism is not the exclusive domain of
domain of one race or another
no race has a monopoly on racism either
as victim or perpetrator
and racism is not necessarily
a crisis because if somebody is racist
and their racism is largely rejected by
the society they live in
then there's not a whole lot of harm
that his racist thoughts can do
his racism is likely to remain mostly in
his thoughts
because it's not accepted by society
where it damages him more than it
damages anybody else
where racism becomes truly dangerous is
where it's accepted by the culture
racism that society embraces even
celebrates is the kind it's the only
kind that can cause widespread harm it's
the only kind that we really have to
worry about but given that society
accepts
this kind of racism most people in
society are not worried about it which
means always that the kind of racism
everyone should worry about
is by definition exactly the kind that
they're not worrying about
and in our culture of course that is
anti-white
racism it is only in a country that
embraces and celebrates anti-white
racism that something like this can
exist according to the film website
collider filmmaker sasha jenkins has
teamed up with
showtime to shine a light on
institutionalized and systemic racism
and a new docu-series titled
everything's going to be all white
in the series trailer viewers hear from
multiple people of color speaking about
their experiences with racism and the
negative impact of whiteness in america
set to debut debut on february 11th the
three-part limited series will feature
interviews with historians artists
activists cultural commentators actors
and more
in a trailer that gives a may trigger
white people disclaimer at its start
several interviewees provide their
commentary on everything from white
fragility to the capital rise of january
2021 through facts historical events and
even some comedy the trailer focuses its
lens on the problematic systems that are
in place to hold people of color down
while elevating caucasians
well this sounds bad already you don't
know the half of it the trailer for this
thing came out a few days ago
and it is maybe the most unabashedly
gleefully racist thing
you'll ever watch in your life take a
look
[Music]
i think what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us
we'll just stop there for a second to
note that it is it is certainly annoying
to be killed i i i agree with you there
but it's very rare
that a white person kills a black person
it's also comparatively rare that a
black person kills a white person white
people tend to kill white people and
black people tend to kill black people
black people make up a hugely
disproportionate number of murder
victims but they're almost all killed by
other black people and as for
interracial murder which again is rare
more whites are killed by black people
than black people by white people
those are the facts
in case they matter to you
back to the trailer
what is fragile about whiteness when
everything has been constructed around
it
every part of who i am has been
distorted or criminalized it's really
just a bunch of white lies
you know fragility is an interesting
concept
let me ask you this
when white people
are told that there's a certain word
they can't say in any context
they can't even utter the syllables no
matter the reason or intention
because of the harm that word will do to
members of the of another race
where is the fragility there who's being
fragile
when a black nfl coach cries that he's
being oppressed because it took him more
than three hours to find a new coaching
job
is that fragility
see as it turns out there's quite a lot
of fragility in our culture
but but it's not that one race or
another is fragile
there is in fact plenty of fragility
among white people too it's that it's
that fragility is cultivated
among members of victim classes
they are treated as fragile
encouraged to be fragile
encouraged to be helpless to be victims
that's where the fragility is well uh
one thing i can tell you as a four-star
chef myself um amateur chef but i
consider myself a four-star chef your
kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami kota kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikoto also uses
steel sourced from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy-duty ash wood
box and makes sure the knife is stored
safely as well each kamikota knife goes
through a rigorous 19-step process that
takes several years from start to finish
to complete our expert blade smiths
forge and shape raw steel into hearty
blades uh polishing and sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident that their knives will
work for you that each knife comes with
a lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikota knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed
kamikoto is currently having a massive
extended new year sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional 50
50 off any purchase you make with
discount code matt walsh so click the
link below or go to kamikoda.com matt
walsh and use promo code matt walsh to
save an extra 50 today all right let's
go back to the trailer
you're not patriots you're ridiculous
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is
ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
hell yeah
white jesus or black jesus jesus was not
white think of geography ain't no way
jesus walked around with blonde hair and
blue eyes
white culture fears the end of the world
for us as native people the end of the
world already happened like multiple
times
symbols and monuments these are mementos
of racism bring that statue that
what about tcby yogurt or something
everybody can get behind
the truth has to be told about history
we have to make sure that these stories
are told from our perspective
all right i think it's probably about
enough of that you know i often hear
just on this on this jesus white jesus
thing i i often hear it insisted that
jesus isn't white
um but the interesting thing is i never
hear anyone insisting that he is white
so race hustlers love to go on and on
about the fact that jesus didn't have
blonde hair and blue eyes
which is a bit like me running around
telling everybody that george washington
wasn't a black guy from nigeria it's
true of course that george washington
wasn't african but by debunking that
idea i'm debunking something that i made
up in my head in the first place in a
similar way
nobody ever said that jesus looked like
he's from sweden
now you might see jesus depicted with
lighter skin in some art but that's
because
nobody knows what jesus looked like
and so it's physical depictions which
are all essentially fictional
because there's no portrait provided to
us in the bible
so people are kind of making it up
that means his physical depictions are
going to reflect the people who create
the depiction black artists will
probably tend to make jesus look a
little bit blacker while white artists
may tend to make him look a little bit
whiter
now jesus i can assure you is not
offended by any of this
in fact jesus doesn't really care if we
get his physical description exactly
right
and i feel comfortable speaking for
jesus on this point
and i know that he doesn't care because
if he did
he would have provided us with that
description
instead of leaving it so conspicuously
absent from the record
and so what that means is that people
again sort of make it up
and as artists
it's going to reflect their
you know it's kind of reflect themselves
in a certain way that's fine not a
problem
now you notice at the end of the clip
we're told that the stories of history
including the gospel story i guess
must be told from our perspective
meaning the non-white perspective
of course anyone who tells a story is
going to be telling it from their own
perspective nobody is suggesting that
black people shouldn't have a
perspective or they shouldn't tell
stories grounded in that perspective but
what he really means what this
documentary along with critical race
theory as a whole is trying to get
across is that the stories of history
and the story of america and the story
of our culture both past and press and
present must be told from a perspective
that is actively antagonistic towards
white people
that's what's really meant
now think about this
is there any country in the non-western
world
where the culture is openly antagonistic
to the nation's predominant race
could something analogous to what i just
played for you
exist in any non-western country
you know something like that targeting
the majority of the people in the
country
on racial grounds
could there be any serious movement
anywhere else
to shame and demonize and exclude and
marginalize the majority race in the
country
has anything like this ever existed
anywhere in history
i think not
and it's gotten to this point now
through years of conditioning
not only the conditioning of non-white
groups to hate white people and blame
them for every problem even and
especially the problems that members of
these other groups largely caused
through their own choices but on top of
that there has to have been a long and
sustained effort to condition white
people to hate themselves hate who they
are
loathe their own identity
it's probably not a coincidence this is
all happening at the same time that
gender ideology takes hold
because all of this comes down to a
hatred and rejection
of yourself
that's the only way that any of this
stuff can happen
that's how we end up with that
the most ridiculously racist
thing put on film in
decades easily
[Music]
and you can watch it on show time
this week
which is why today we must say that
showtime is cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated